What on earth is going on!?
One minute, I was just doing my job, protecting
the President of the United States from any
potential attacks.
The next thing I knew, thousands of people
were dead, the world was thrown into chaos,
and this so-called “SCP Foundation” had
declared war on the human race!?
Okay, okay, let’s get back to Day 1 before
things get too confusing.
Day 1.
I’m a member of the President’s secret
service, so it’s my job to keep POTUS safe
from all manner of potential dangers.
My son, Thomas, was in the care of my ex-wife
across the state when everything went south.
It started on the white house lawn, where
the president was giving a speech about his
plans to shrink the deficit.
That’s when he appeared.
A stranger slipped into the press junket.
He was dressed like a British butler.
It was almost comical.
Myself and the other agents immediately flagged
him as a potential threat and moved in to
intercept him.
That’s when things went nuts.
This Butler was one of the greatest fighters
I’ve ever seen - He effortlessly disarmed
the intercepting agents, and while we desperately
tried to wrestle the president off the stage,
the Butler stole one of my fellow agent’s
pistols, and blew off the president’s head
with one perfectly-aimed shot.
Of course, we returned fire, mowing the Butler
down in a hail of bullets.
But it was already too late.
People were screaming and running.
I could see, out in the city beyond, there
were explosions.
Smoke rising.
A cacophony of screams.
In an instant, everything had changed.
We all hunkered down in the White House to
protect the Vice President.
That’s when, upon turning on the news, we
saw The Message.
It’d been sent to every company, every station.
It read:
The following is a message composed via consensus
of the O5 Council.
For those who are not currently aware of our
existence, we represent the organization known
as the SCP Foundation.
Our previous mission centered around the containment
and study of anomalous objects, entities,
and other assorted phenomena.
This mission was the focus of our organization
for more than one hundred years.
Due to circumstances outside of our control,
this directive has now changed.
Our new mission will be the extermination
of the human race.
There will be no further communication.
Day 2.
Of course, I tried to get through to my ex-wife
and check that she and Thomas were okay, but
by that time, communication had already broken
down.
Strangely, the internet and major TV news
channels remained in operation, allowing them
to spew a constant barrage of the horrors
going on outside.
All over the world, hideous monsters and malicious
creatures had flooded the streets, killing
human beings en masse.
I don’t understand, is the SCP Foundation
behind all this?
I hadn’t even heard of them until yesterday,
and now, they were apparently releasing living
nightmares everywhere, apparently with the
intent of wiping out the human race.
All I could do was stay in place, hope my
family was staying safe, and do what I can
to protect the Vice President.
Day 3.
The Vice President is dead.
The same could be said for the rest of my
team.
Some terrifying, zombie-like man somehow breached
our security perimeter and melted down the
president and six secret service agents into
a thick, black sludge.
Obviously, not an ideal situation.
At that point, the chain of command collapsed
entirely and we decided to make a run for
it.
Bullets didn’t seem to work on that rotting
old freak, and I’m not the kind of idiot
who sees the point in expending a few extra
magazines on a lost cause.
But by the time I was outside, it was already
nightfall, and the horrors were just beginning…
Day 4.
It’s hell on earth out here.
I was wandering the streets of DC, trying
my best to remain scarce despite the chaos
unfolding all around me.
There were these creatures - abominations
of human flesh, twisted into unimaginably
unnatural configurations - roaming around,
attacking any humans they saw.
And anyone they touched started to transform
into more of them.
I decided to sleep in the back room of a ransacked
post office that night.
I didn’t want to move in the dark with these
things around.
One touch, and I’d be dead.
No thank you.
Day 5.
Why the hell did they do this to us!?
These monsters at the SCP Foundation, flooding
the world with abominations intent on ending
human life.
One of those flesh monsters almost killed
me today.
I was trying to sneak down a back alley when
I heard the chittering of bony legs following
me.
I turned and saw it, reaching out towards
me with fleshy tendrils.
I raised my handgun and fired several times,
to no effect.
I was preparing for death, or worse, when
some huge, metal vehicle I couldn’t recognize
pulled into the alley.
Men spilled out of it - Well, they weren’t
just men, they were cyborgs, in heavy, technologically-advanced
armor and weapons straight out of Star Wars.
They burned the creature to death with a volley
of concentrated heat beams.
I thanked my rescuers profusely and asked
them their names.
They simply told me:
“We’re devotees of the Broken God.
Stay safe out there, fellow traveler.
Mekhane be with you.”
Day 6.
I wasn’t just surviving for my own sake,
you need to understand that.
I wanted to get back to my ex-wife and son
as quickly as possible, knowing all the horrors
that the SCP Foundation had unleashed onto
the world for no logical reason.
As morbid as it sounds, even if we all died,
I’d rather we die together than apart.
But every day, I developed a new reason to
know this journey wouldn’t be easy.
While trying to escape from one of DC’s
more densely-packed urban areas, I encountered
a horrific monster.
It looked like a giant, mutant crocodile the
size of a bus, vicious as hell, and it could
talk.
When it clapped its eyes on me, it growled
“Disgusting…” and started running towards
me.
But the actual physical structure of DC saved
my ass this time.
You see, the streets of DC are designed to
give in and collapse if ever huge military
vehicles roll over them, in order to prevent
the capital from being invaded by a military
force.
The reptile clearly didn’t know this, cause
it seemed awful confused when the ground gave
out underneath it, and I was able to run to
safety while it tried to scramble up the walls.
Day 7.
A week into this hellish new world, and against
all odds, I’m still alive.
Though it’s not for lack of trying from
the gaggle of killer freaks the monsters at
the SCP Foundation have unleashed to terrorize
the streets.
Today, I saw something terrifying.
A man was lured into a dark corner by the
voice of a young child, claiming to be his
daughter.
He approached the dark with tears in his eyes
when a pack of monsters jumped out and began
devouring him alive.
Their long, sharp fangs and raw red hides
are going to linger in my dreams forever.
You can’t trust voices anymore.
You can’t trust them.
Day 8.
I’m almost at the edge of the city, but
the nightmares continue.
I was able to narrowly dodge a group of men
walking in perfect step, like one of those
flash mobs that always used to pop up.
In the middle of them, there was a woman with
what looked like some kind of strange skin
condition.
They didn’t seem all that aggressive until
they came upon a pair of women also trying
to make their way out of the city.
The men in the trancelike state charged at
them, holding the women in place and seeming
to strangle them while the woman with the
skin condition just laughed.
I would have charged in there to help, but
there were maybe twenty of the hypnotized
men in the group, and with one magazine of
handgun ammo left, even with perfect aim I
couldn’t drop them all.
But the guilt of leaving those women to die
will stay with me forever.
Over the next nine days, I encountered zombies.
I kid you not, genuine, honest-to-god zombies,
the Walking God Damn Dead, infesting a road
on the edge of town.
There was a huge crowd of them, gurgling and
growling, skin looking green and rotten.
I’ve seen so many zombie movies, but seeing
the genuine article in person was still utterly
revolting.
When they spotted me and started running towards
me, I instinctively pulled out my weapon and
fired several times.
I scored a couple of respectable headshots,
but they just kept coming.
The only thing I could do was run into a nearby
gas station and lock the door behind me.
For a second there, I thought I was doomed
until I suddenly developed the wherewithal
to check behind the cash register - Where,
to my immense luck, the clerk had apparently
left a pump-action shotgun with several shells.
With the extra firepower, I snuck out of the
back of the gas station, approached the zombie
horde from behind, and executed them with
a series of well-chosen shots.
I managed to steal and refuel a car to get
out of town.
On the way out, just to add to the surreality
of this whole situation, I saw a witch in
a ditch.
Sounds like I just made it up for the rhyme,
but no, there was a genuine witch hiding in
the grass, chewing on a dead body.
That was the moment that I knew, on some level,
that things would never be normal again.
The best I could hope for was survival.
The 21 days after that were incredibly eventful,
to say the least.
Thank god I had the foraged shotgun with me,
or I would have been a goner, because almost
as soon as I left town, that huge, monstrous
lizard appeared again, carrying a dead deer
in its mouth.
Had it followed me, or was it just a coincidence
that I ran into it again?
Hell, maybe there was more than one of those
horrible dinosaurs out there.
But the second it noticed me driving by, it
immediately began to chase me.
I put the pedal to the metal and hoped beyond
hope that this monster wouldn’t catch up
with me, but I kept seeing it get bigger and
bigger in my rear-view mirror.
That creature was impossibly fast for its
size, and believe me when I saw it was getting
close, I started sweating.
With a sharp turn at a crucial moment, I was
able to gain a vital lead and lose the beast.
Soon enough, it was no longer in my peripherals,
which was exactly how I liked it.
Then I ran into a gaggle of horrific creatures
that I can hardly even explain.
I was getting out of my stolen car to forage
for food in a nearby supermarket when suddenly
I was swarmed by what I can only describe
as a group of…
Human chicken monsters?
As stupid as they sound compared to the other
things I’ve faced, they were fast and incredibly
aggressive.
I was lucky to dodge a few of their brutal
charges and retaliate with a few blasts from
the shotgun, which at least bought me time
to escape - Even though I had to abandon my
car.
Easy come, easy go seem to be the rules of
this terrible new world.
Are they ever going to run out of horrible
beasts to throw at me?
Let’s see…
Over the eleven days that followed, between
periods of pure hiding, I actually had a first-hand
confrontation with agents of the SCP Foundation.
After the things I’ve seen, if I could punch
every single one of them so hard that they’d
never wake up, I’d do it, in a heartbeat.
It was their fault that all of this was happening,
and we’d never even know why.
Well, that’s not entirely true.
I was able to get myself some answers the
hard way…
I saw a helicopter circling above while I
was hiding behind a small collection of buildings.
They were shining a spotlight around, and
any time they saw a person walking out into
the open, they ruthlessly gunned them down.
When one person managed to duck away and run
through a narrow alley, the helicopter landed
and several men in tactical gear with assault
rifles stepped out.
When I recognized the SCP Foundation logo
on the side of the chopper, I felt my blood
rising to boil.
These were the ones who killed all these people.
As they began to disperse, I approached from
behind with murder in my eyes, and used the
shotgun to kill several of them.
Before any of them had a chance to retaliate,
I grabbed one of their fallen assault rifles
and fired back, killing or injuring them all.
The ones that were heavily injured were incapacitated,
but oddly, they didn’t seem to be in pain.
I aimed the gun at one of their heads and
told them to tell me why they were doing all
this.
That SCP Foundation foot soldier just smiled
and said, “You’re never going to know
how much we helped you.
But that’s okay.
We’re used to dying in the dark.
You’ll have to learn.”
So of course, I shot him in the head.
Hey, wouldn’t you?
I was better armed than ever, soon enough.
I had a new sidearm and an assault rifle,
along with a hell of a lot of ammo, from the
fallen SCP Foundation agents.
I took a little joy in the irony that the
SCP Foundation, the ones behind all this,
had provided me with the tools to defy their
reign of terror.
But none of that prepared me for that maniac
in the mask.
After getting a few days' rest in a basement
apartment I broke into, I emerged to continue
the journey.
I was maybe about fifty miles away from where
my ex and son were living, if they’d managed
to somehow stay put and survive all this time.
But when I left the basement apartment, something
was waiting for me.
It was a man wearing a white comedy mask,
dripping with this strange, black gunk, and
carrying a fire axe.
“Well hello there, good sir!” he said
with a laugh.
“How lovely to meet you.
It’s been a while since I’ve seen another
one like you.
You look like you’re carrying a lot of weight
on your shoulders, but don’t worry!
I can help with that!”
He gave a diabolical laugh and swung the axe
at my head.
I was able to narrowly dodge the blow and
return fire into center-mass with my rifle.
He seemed unfazed.
He just laughed and started charging forwards
with another swing from the axe.
Rather than shooting him again, and potentially
attracting some unwanted attention, I decided
to just run for it.
Every day, there are new surprises out here…
I made my way through a small town that had
been utterly decimated.
Homes and buildings were empty.
A huge stack of human corpses sat in the center
of town.
On top of the pile there stood a heavily tattooed
man, carrying a huge, black blade in each
hand.
He was clashing the blades together and calling
out, “This world has no worthy opponents
for the mighty Able!
Step forward and meet my blade, so at least
you can die with honor, you sad, timid little
sheep!”
I didn’t feel like dying with honor that
day, so I instead chose to discretely make
my way across the town, hoping that the “Mighty
Able” wouldn’t notice me.
And this paid off in the end, as I was able
to find an abandoned motorcycle, and high-tail
it out of there with all of my scavenged weaponry.
At long last, I was so damn close…
Just before day 90, that monstrous reptile
came back.
I swear to god, that monster is following
me, it’s more than just a coincidence now.
I was no more than twenty miles from my ex’s
place, driving at great speeds on my newly
purloined motorcycle when the giant, scaly
monster emerged from the side of the road
and knocked me off my bike.
If I didn’t think quickly and rely on my
training, I would have been killed - I’d
done two tours with the marine corps in Afghanistan
before being selected for defending the president,
a job that, technically, I’d failed miserably
at.
But those skills might be the only thing that
could let me stand a chance against this monster.
It reared up and tried to attack me again.
I used my stolen assault rifle to concentrate
fire on its eyes, trying to at least distract
it.
Its wounds healed quickly, and the pain of
the blasts doesn’t seem to have affected
it in the slightest.
But every time it lunges for me, I’m lucky
enough to have the room to dodge it.
This isn’t sustainable - I know that it
will have energy long after I tire.
What I need is a distraction so I can get
the hell out of here.
Then, an idea hits me!
I turn the gun on the motorcycle’s fuel
tank and fire off a few rounds.
BOOM!
A nice, big, distracting fireball.
It buys me a few seconds, but that’s enough
to let me get away down a narrow alley and
make myself disappear.
All I can say is, I really hope I don’t
see that monster again.
Isn’t three times enough for one life?
Just when you think things can’t get any
stranger, you see something that almost breaks
your brain with its sheer surrealness.
While traveling through the town next to the
one where my ex and son live, I saw a heart.
Like a giant, beating heart, on spider legs
with a scorpion tail, destroying everything.
It was tearing buildings apart and somehow
setting people on fire with its caustic venom.
What on earth was the SCP Foundation that
it even knew about all these things?
I just kept walking, avoiding attention.
It’s all I could do.
It’s all anyone can do.
No one is saving a world like this, they’re
just avoiding getting killed in it.
Or helping someone they love to avoid getting
killed.
Speaking of, only one day off now.
Only one day off…
Day 100.
I arrived.
After all this hell, after seeing all this
nightmarish carnage that I’ll never be able
to unsee, I’ve reached the home of the ones
I love.
The ones I’ve been surviving for.
I walk up to the front door, step inside,
and find that the house is…
Empty.
Not a soul in sight.
For a moment, I’m terrified.
Had they been killed?
There was no blood.
No bodies.
No sign of anything out of the ordinary.
That means that, like myself, maybe they were
on the move.
Maybe they were fleeing to find safety of
their own.
And if that was the case, I had a pretty good
feeling that I’d know exactly where they
are.
But my thoughts were interrupted by a loud
rumbling noise, coming from the house’s
basement…
Now go check out “SCP-5000 Why?
- The Full Story Compilation” and “How
SCP-682 Tried to Stop SCP-5000” for more
from this horrifyingly apocalyptic scenario!